[Music]
so when I think about what ideas that I
want to like pursue I think about three
questions the first question that I
asked myself is what sucks in my world
does this thing suck in my world so much
that that I want to do something about
it and that like for example having
period accidents every month having to
literally like when I was going to the
bathroom prior to like you know like
bringing tushy into the world I would
have to go to the bathroom
take take I was one using the the
average American uses 57 sheets of
toilet paper per day I was I was that
person using probably more I would take
two wads of toilet paper push to put
them under the sink
I would so I'd have to wet like wads of
toilet paper because I wouldn't buy wet
wipes those are bad for the plumbing
systems and bad for the environment so I
get two wads of wet then it would take
then I would go to the bathroom they
would take the first wet wad and I would
like wipe and that would take dry paper
out of white then take the second wet
water I'd wipe they take more dry paper
I wipe and I would just do this whole
thing to just make sure I'm clean down
there and so it was just like such a you
know so like what sucked in my world
going through that process what sucked
in my world having stomachaches every
time I pizza' regular conventional pizza
you know
bleached flour processed cheese sugar
filled sauces you know processed
toppings I was hurting me but I love
pizza I wanted to you know keep it in my
life but I couldn't eat that kind of
pizza and so that sucked in my world
second question is does it suck for a
lot of people because if it sucks for
just you and you're like a diva then
sorry but that's probably not a great
business idea but if it sucks for a lot
of people then business opportunity one
in five Americans eat gluten-free
whether they're a you know gluten
intolerant or not you know gluten does
require a lot of energy for your body to
break down it's not really great for
your for your body to digest and so to
be able to eat gluten free actually does
keep you later and so 20% of Americans
eat gluten free that's a pretty big
market okay we can start this this
business in this category in the bin
sort of the bidet world or in the
bathroom world you know wiping your butt
with dry paper kind of sucks for a lot
of people specifically the thirty
million combined cases of chronic UTIs
hemorrhoids these infections those who
suffer from those
and just everyone who has to sit on
fecal matter all day long which is
pretty much everyone and so it sucks for
everyone and you know the final question
which is the most important one is can I
be passionate about this issue cause or
community for a really long time you
know it takes ten years to be an
overnight success we often think that
like oh my god Dollar Shave Club sold
two years for a billion dollars
oh look at Instagram had 10 people sold
for a billion dollars I can do this
those are literally like winning the
lottery you know people like you have to
feel like you can sit in that discomfort
for 10 years can you sit in that oh god
am I gonna succeed am I not am I gonna
like just hand-to-mouth figuring it out
how to live during that period can you
do it for 10 years that thing can you be
passionate about that issue for 10 years
so for me all of my businesses have a
cause attached to it for tushy every
bday sold we're helping fund clean
latrine projects all over India to date
we've helped over 12,000 families Gainax
as a clean sanitation through a
partnership with Samara which is an
organization that builds clean latrines
all over India you know right now the
global sanitation crisis is a billion
you know it's a over a billion people
practice open defecation the global
sanitation crisis is one of the greatest
killers of our time I'm half Indian my
father came to this country with five
dollars in his pocket from India and and
you know that could have been my life
you know he came here he met my Japanese
mother it kind of like they fell in love
and in one generation built the American
dream for us but for so many people they
just don't have that and so for me like
what keeps me going is that not only am
i changing culture in you know the first
world by introducing a product that
helps save the environment help save
your health and hygiene but also we're
helping fight the global sanitation
crisis which is helping truly people
just gain just basic access for human
dignity and so that sort of really keeps
me excited and I think you know having
that passion that purpose and that thing
in that you can be like when you close
your eyes and be like can I sit in this
for 10 years my answer is yes across the
board so I think if that is your answer
to then go for it so why I chose to be a
social entrepreneur instead of a
traditional entrepreneur I mean I think
first of all the future of
entrepreneurship is social
entrepreneurship I don't think you can
start a business without it being
a social like that has a cause attached
to it because if there's two products
that are the same and one has a cause
and one dozen who will you support
obviously when that that has a cause
attached to its and secondly as an
entrepreneur when you are like you know
crawling up a hill in molasses like
trying to just make it and keep your
head above like the Death Zone which by
the way between 60 and 95 percent of
businesses closer than the first or
second year you know it's a it's a
really daunting thing to start and grow
you know what keeps us motivated that
when you close your eyes you can say for
every you know product sold I'm helping
support someone in desparate who'd
really desperately need something like
this or desperately needs to have a
solve for what their issue is like the
global sanitation crisis and so for me
you know I I think for any entrepreneur
social enterprise actually drives you
further and keeps you keeps you going
for 10 years instead of just kind of
like trying to create a t-shirt company
so you can sell as many as you can and
then sell to hopefully like Target and
make your millions which you know you
can't start a business like that to be
personal inauthentic people will see
right through it people who start
businesses for the exit most of them
will fail because there's just no true
passion behind it to really really
succeed you have to have such deep
passion and drive to make it succeed and
when you when you're going through the
worst of times you close your eyes you
really have to remember like oh my god
I've helped so many people just gain
access to clean sanitation that's gonna
keep me going most people you know can't
say that if they're just trying to sell
a t-shirt company so
[Music]
you